اعود اليك الياس كرام وللد ايضا وفق مصادر
اسرائيليه فان هذه الدفعه من الصواريخ
انطلقت من شمال القطاع فهل نحن نتحدث عن
عمليات من الشمال ام من الوسط الان في هذه
الصواريخ التي تنطلق وايضا فيما يتعلق
بالقصف الذي نشاهده على الهواء من قبل
قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مياده دعيني فقط اشير الى
الخبر العاجل الذي تورده الان بلديه
نتيفوت التي تعرضت لهذا القصف الصاروخي
وبحسب تقديرات البلديه فان 50 صاروخا
اشتملت هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه التي اطلقت
من قطاع غزه باتجاه هذه المدينه الواقعه
في النقب الغربي وما يحيط بها من بلدات
اسرائيليه اذا 50 صاروخا ضمن هذه الدفعه
الصاروخيه وعنا عندما قلت في بدايه هذه
المداخله بانها كانت دفعه صاروخيه هائله
نحن لم نبالغ بذلك لاننا القصف عمليا
داهمنا ونحن في طريقنا الى هذا الموقع
وكانت الاعتراضات الصاروخيه حقيقه فوق
رؤوسنا هائله وكبيره للغايه ونحن قدرنا
بالفعل بان يكون عدد الصواريخ كبيرا جدا
في هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه لكن الان من
المصادر الرسميه الاسرائيليه وتحديدا من
بلديه نتيفوت تتحدث البلديه عن ان 50
صاروخا اطلق باتجاه هذه المدينه ضمن هذه
الدفعه الصاروخيه الهائله والكبيره التي
وجهت صوب هذه المدينه وبعض هذه الصواريخ
افلتت ايه من منظومه القبه الحديديه وسقطت
في داخل المدينه واحدثت دمارا في احد
المباني هناك لكن الاسعاف الاسرائيلي حتى
هذه الساعه لم يبلغ عن وقوع اصابات في
صفوف الاسرائيليين بطبيعه الحال تحدث الان
عمليات تمشيط واسعه كما جرت العاده من
جانب قوى الامن الاسرائيليه وكذلك الشرطه
الاسرائيليه التي عاده ما تصل الى مواقع
سقوط هذه الصواريخ وتغلقها و تمنع الوصول
اليها وبطبيعه الحال ياتي خبراء المتفجرات
ايضا الى تلك المواقع لمعاينتها والتاكد
من ان بقايا الصواريخ التي سقطت في داخل
المدينه خاليه من بقايا متفجرات قد تشكل
اي خطر نشير هنا ايضا مياده الى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي وفي اعقاب هذه الدفعه
الصاروخيه الكبيره والهائل التي وجهت صوب
النقب الغربي عاجله الى اطلاق دفعه من
المدفعيه الثقيله باتجاه المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه تحديدا في منطقه جباليا وايضا
في الموقع الذي اطلقت منه الصواريخ اي في
منطقه ال الوسط كانت هنالك دفعات متتاليه
وشديده من القصف المدفعي ترافق كما جاء
قبل قليل ونحن معكم على الهواء مباشره
مياده ايضا من خلال هذه المروحيه العسكريه
من نوع اباتشي التي كانت تحوم في اجواء
الم منطقه واطلقت على الاقل صاروخين
باتجاه ما يعتقد ربما انها منصه الصواريخ
التي انطلقت منها هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه
باتجاه مدينه نتيفوت وكما تسمعين ربما
بالخلفيه مياده ان المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
ما زالت تواصل قصفها المدفعي لمواقع عده
في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه نستطيع ان
نرصد من المكان الذي نقف فيه هنا ان
الضربات
المدفعيه وان كانت تتركز في في منطقه
المخيمات الوسطى تحديدا في منطقه البريج
لكن هنالك عده سحب دخان تنبعث من اكثر من
منطقه في
مدينه غزه ومن بين هذه المناطق المنطقه
الجنوبيه او الضواحي الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه
هنالك ايضا سحب
دخان نراها ايضا من منطقه الشجاعيه وكذلك
في منطقه جباليا التي شهدت ايضا في
الدقائق الاخيره قصفا مدفعيا شديدا وسمع
ايضا اشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله
هذه التطورات مياده تاتي بعد اعلان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يوم امس انسحاب الفرقه 36 على
اليتها بما في ذلك الويه المدرعات ولواء
جولاني بكامله وهو واحد من الويه النخبه و
راس الحربه في العمليات البريه وبالتالي
كثير من الاسئله تسال الان عبر
التلفزيونات الاسرائيليه والاستديوهات
التحليليه حول ما الذي فعله الجيش
الاسرائيلي او ما لم يفعله حقيقه على مدى
اكثر من 100 يوم من عمر هذه الحرب لانه
واضح انه بعد انسحاب الجيش الاسرائيلي
وسحب هذه الفرقه وهذه القوات اي عادت ال
المقاومه الفلسطينيه لتظهر قدراتها
الصاروخيه الهائله التي ما زالت تتمتع بها
وما زالت قادره على توجيه هذه الصواريخ
باتجاه المدن الاسرائيليه وكان شيئا لم
يكن وكان العمليه العسكريه لم تنجز شيئا
وكان بيانات الناطق العسكري حول القضاء
على المقاومه والقضاء على قدراتها ال
العسكريه والصاروخيه على الاقل ان اردنا
ان نوصفها لم تكن صحيحه ولم تكن ايه دقيقه
وبالتالي نحن نرى انه منذ لم لي امس هنالك
اشتداد ايضا من جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه
لتوجيه ضربات باتجاه غلاف غزه مدينه ديروت
والبلدات القريبه منها تعرضت ليله ليله
امس الى دفعه صاروخيه كبيره وهذه الدفعه
الصاروخيه التي نوصفها بانها كانت هائله
وحقيقه هي كانت هائله كانت تضم 50 صاروخا
ايه دفعه واحده وهذا بتاكيد من ال بلديه
نتيفوت التي قالت بان 50 صاروخا كان وجهها
صوب المدينه في هذه الدفعه الاخيره